- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to today's Homeroom livestream.
Today, it's just going to be me.
So we're gonna do another ask me anything.
So if you have any questions for me
literally about anything,
start putting them on the message boards
on Facebook or YouTube,
wherever you're watching this.
And we have team members
who will surface the questions to me.
So please start thinking about those.
But before we jump into
the ask me anything,
I'll give my standard announcement
reminder that Khan Academy is
a not-for-profit organization
and we can only exist through donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to KhanAcademy.org/donate
and making a donation.
And our last guest where we talked
about what makes folks happy,
what are the things that
can actually make you
a happier person is giving to others.
So when you donate to Khan Academy,
that is going to give to
many, many, many other folks
the power of their potential
of their education.
It's going to make you a much
happier person because of it.
Also I'd like to give a shout out
to several corporations who I'm guessing
are also now happier corporations
because they've stepped up as Khan Academy
had to step up during COVID,
our costs went up, our
server costs went up,
we've been trying to accelerate programs
and they helped us fill this gap.
But we still need more help,
but special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
Also wanna remind folks
about Homeroom with Sal, the podcast.
The podcast version of
what we're doing right now
edited down a little
bit for podcast purposes
and it's safe to consume
while you're driving
or doing other things that
you might need your eyes for.
So check that out wherever
you find your podcasts.
So with that, let's get
into the ask me anything.
And there's one that we got a little ahead
of time from Dolce Castro Garcia.
This was actually I think on
the last one from Thursday,
but I figured it's a good place to start.
Dolce wrote, "Mr. Kahn, until this live,"
I guess this live stream,
"I didn't know who had made the platform
I love working on so much.
How did you get the idea
to make the platform
or what inspired you?
Thank you so much. I'll
make sure to donate."
Well, Dolce, thank you
so much that you enjoy
working on Khan Academy.
A lot of folks talk about
people having a growth mindset
and people with a growth mindset
are constantly challenging themselves
and pushing their boundaries
and people with a growth mindset
are also disproportionately
successful in life.
And the fact that it sounds
like you like going to Khan
Academy, challenging yourself,
keep pushing the boundaries
of your knowledge,
I think says a lot about you
and hopefully will be a small part
in you becoming an
incredibly empowered person.
And thanks for the willingness to donate
if you're in a position to do so.
In terms of where the
inspiration for Khan Academy
came from, you know, it
goes pretty far back.
Khan Academy immediately started
getting worked on in 2004
when one of my cousins needed help.
I was an analyst at a
hedge fund at the time.
My original background was
in math and computer science
and I had worked in tech as well,
but I started tutoring her,
word spread through my family
free tutoring was going on.
I soon found myself tutoring
10/15 cousins around the country.
I started writing software for them
because I saw a common pattern
is that they all had
gaps in their knowledge.
And I wanted some ways
for them to practice
and fill in those gaps.
And for me as their
teacher or their tutor,
to monitor what they were doing
so that when we got on the phone,
we could dig a little bit deeper.
And that was the first Khan Academy,
that exercise platform I wrote for them.
And it actually still is
the core of Khan Academy,
this notion to be able to practice
and get as much feedback as you need.
And then it was a friend
in 2006 who suggested
that I make videos to
supplement the exercise portion
of Khan Academy and
upload them onto YouTube.
I thought it was a horrible idea.
I told them YouTube is
for cats playing piano,
not serious mathematics,
but I got over the idea
that it wasn't my idea.
And I gave it a shot.
And you know,
my cousins famously told
me they liked me better
on YouTube than in-person.
Take that how you will.
What they were saying is
that they really appreciate
having an on-demand version,
an infinitely repeatable version
of their cousin that they could watch
in the middle of the night, no judgment,
but they still enjoyed having
the phone calls with me.
But, you know, and then
became clear people
who are not my cousins
were using this resource
and not just the software,
but the videos as well.
By 2009, I had set up Khan Academy
as a not-for-profit organization.
To be clear what a not-for-profit is,
no one owns a not-for-profit.
I don't own Khan Academy.
You own as much of Khan Academy
as I own of Khan Academy.
None of us own, it's really for society.
But I set it up as a
not-for-profit and I said,
well, the social return
on investment on this,
the social impact could
be through the roof.
I set it up with the mission
of free world class education
for anyone anywhere.
And even though at that time
there were about 50 or a
100 thousand folks using it,
I imagined and I was operating
out of the same closet where I am now,
that maybe one day it could be millions,
10 millions, hundreds of
millions, billions of folks.
And so I quit my day job
and tried to find
philanthropic funding for it.
And that first year was a very tough year.
I think anytime you do
anything entrepreneurial,
you almost have to have
that delusional optimism,
assume that people are gonna step up
and realize what you think you realize
but it always takes a little
bit more time than you suspect.
And so it was actually very,
very stressful that 2009.
Our first child had just been born,
our expenses went up,
my wife was still in
training to be a physician.
So it was hard.
But as we got kind of month 9, month 10,
then some philanthropists
started to come out of the woodwork.
And then by that fall,
some major foundations,
Google.org, the Gates
Foundation stepped up
for us to become a real organization.
So that was really the
genesis of Khan Academy
and it's been a ongoing ride ever since.
And it's all because of support
from both the large
foundations and corporations
and folks like yourself
that make this possible
because right now we're
only really throttled back
by how much resources we can apply
to this problem that
affects all of humanity.
But thanks for that question,
Dolce, I think was your name.
And then let's see, YouTube, Anuj Pagwan,
"You can be a billionaire
but what you are doing free,
what is your source of energy?"
Anuj, well, I guess you
were making illusion
to like maybe if Khan
Academy was for-profit,
I would own some of it
and it could go public
and maybe be worth billions, maybe.
I did the thought experiment
back when I was deciding
whether to make Khan Academy
for-profit or nonprofit,
and I live in Silicon Valley.
And so there were some venture capitalists
who were reaching out
at the time and saying,
"Hey, our kids use Khan Academy.
We think you're onto something.
We'll write a quick
check for you right now.
You can quit your job, start doing it.
And we think this could be
a really successful ed
tech for-profit company."
And it was tempting because I
could immediately work on it.
Maybe if it's successful,
I could be a billionaire
which, you know, I could
dress better, et cetera.
But then when I really thought
about what would I do
with a billion dollars,
yes, I would probably maybe
dress a little bit better.
I probably wouldn't even dress any better.
I have everything I need.
Even back then I kinda
had everything I need.
I have a wonderful family,
a smart, beautiful,
amazing, intelligent wife.
I have now, at the time I had one son,
but now I have two sons and a daughter.
They're incredibly fun
and give me incredible
energy and contentment.
And you know, if you have those things
and if you have enough
resources to pay your mortgage,
go on vacations every now and then,
go to a restaurant every now and then,
so you're not struggling financially,
which you know, growing up,
my mom raised us by herself
and she worked a lot of minimum wage jobs.
So I know how hard it is when
you struggle financially.
But if you're not struggling financially,
if you have your base necessities,
we have two Hondas,
what else could I want?
And Honda doesn't even pay
me, I just keep buying Hondas.
I'm not trying to be some type
of social media influencer,
I've just always been
kind of a fan of Hondas,
they haven't let me down.
But I was like, what would
I do with more money?
I would probably just donate it all
to an effort like Khan Academy.
And so why why not
even, why wait for that,
just do it in reverse.
Do the philanthropy in reverse.
Just go straight to the not-for-profit
and then try to find other folks
who are aligned to help fund it.
And, you know, I do
collect a salary from it.
Everyone at Khan Academy,
we're paid to do what we do,
but obviously we're not paid in stock.
We're not gazillionaires and
billionaires and all of that,
but I'm very happy with that
trade off personally in life.
We had Francis Ford Coppola
on several months ago
and he brought up this
term called, you know,
in life, a lot of people are
trying to become millionaires
or millionaires are trying
to become billionaires
but he coined a new term
called sufficientaire.
And that's when you have enough.
And if in your mind
you're a sufficientaire,
you're actually the wealthiest of all,
because I know people
who are probably worth
a billion who wanna be worth two billion
and they're kind of waking
up in the middle of the night
like, how am I gonna
make the next billion?
But if you're sufficientaire,
then you have enough.
And I consider myself a sufficientaire.
I have hopefully a reasonable
financial security,
have all what I need, and
I get to work on a mission
that I care about, I get to
work with incredible people,
I get to do goofy things like
these AMAs every now and then
as part of my job, it's
intellectually challenging.
So what else could I ask for?
So I have no regrets at all.
So let's see, from YouTube,
Cade Heppelmann says,
"What makes you most proud
of with Khan Academy?"
You know, when I meet
folks either virtually
or I meet 'em in-person
and they say that it's had
an impact on their life.
I've gone through airport security
and the person who's
walking me into the scanner
all of a sudden says,
"Hey, you look familiar."
And then they hear me talk, they're like,
"You sound a lot like
that Khan Academy guy."
And I'm like, well, "I
am the Khan Academy guy."
And then they'll start talking
about how it helped them,
how it got them through high school
or how it got them through college.
And it feels really good to
have that type of feedback,
to hear those stories
when you're doing an
otherwise not pleasant thing,
like trying to check
into airport security.
And we get letters all of the time
and that really is what
gives me a lot of energy
and gives me a lot of satisfaction.
And that you know,
I tell this to the Khan
Academy team all the time,
these are the stories we hear about,
but we know that there's tens of millions
of folks on the platform.
So that there's literally stadiums full
of people right now who are learning,
who are tapping into their potential
because of Khan Academy that might not
have otherwise been able to.
And for me, I just think
about all of that human
potential that is growing
and growing and growing.
I remember reading a story
about Warren Buffett.
This was well before
I started Khan Academy
but they asked him about his investment
in Gillette, which makes shaving razors.
And he says, "I sleep very well at night
just imagining all the hair growing
on all the men's faces around the world.
And that's just going to drive
the profits of Gillette."
Well, my analog is I go to sleep
and I just imagine all of the people
who are not the hair is growing
but their intellect is growing.
Their neurons are connecting
because of Khan Academy.
And hopefully their self-esteem is growing
because they're able to
tap into their potential.
And I don't think there's
anything more exciting than that.
And selfishly, all of you who
are growing intellectually
and your self-esteem and
your confidence is growing,
you're gonna do amazing things.
Many of those things are going to benefit
all of us, including me.
So it'll all come back.
One of y'all are gonna find a cure
for some disease or solve
climate change or part of it,
or write the next great novel.
And hopefully if Khan Academy plays
a little small part of
it, that'd be incredible.
Let's see, from Facebook, Patrick Breslin,
"How can we improve the online
learning classroom experience
ideas and improvements
in 2020 and beyond?"
Well, there's some high-level things
that actually don't need technology.
I think the interactive
live video conference
is crucial especially if
you're doing distance learning.
Now, to be clear, I don't
think distance learning,
100% distance learning is not optimal
for most people, including for myself.
You need to be in a classroom,
interact with people, see body language.
That stuff is super powerful.
I mean, obviously during COVID,
we have to do distance
learning and then beyond COVID,
there could be spaces for
it where it gives you access
to courses that might not be available
in your school or connected to students
who you might not otherwise
be able to connect with.
But whenever you're
doing anything distanced,
especially video conference,
you gotta make it as
interactive as possible.
I mean, if I just lecture
to y'all right now
without looking at your questions,
it might as well be a video.
And ideally, if we're all really
live on a video conference,
I should be asking you all questions
and seeing your responses,
putting you into breakout sessions,
being creative on the use of time.
Instead of 60 minutes with 30 kids,
why not six 10-minute
sessions with five kids each
so you can get a little
bit more personalization.
Break it up every now and
then with just fun activities,
close your eyes and draw an elephant
and then share it with everyone.
Maybe in a breakout session.
Those are the types of things
that when we see are done
well, make it really engaging.
And frankly, everything I just
said are also good practices
in a physical classroom,
make it as interactive as
possible, human to human.
From YouTube, Hari Aburu says,
"How did you manage to
upload millions of videos,
helping millions of people?"
Well, Hari, to be clear,
Khan Academy is much more than just me.
And I haven't uploaded millions of videos.
Personally, I have made
thousands of videos.
I think it's probably be about
6,000 or 7,000 at this point.
And it seems like a lot,
but when you look at how many
days in the year there are
times I've been making videos
for about 14 years now,
yeah, you can get several thousand,
if you think about, yeah,
if you say roughly over
10 years 7,000 videos,
I mean, I've been doing it
for a little bit more than 10 years,
you're looking at about 700 videos a year.
If you think I've been doing
it for about 12, 13, 14 years,
it's a little bit lower,
maybe 500/600 videos a year.
And so that's averaging about,
there's about 250 work days,
so I'm averaging about two
to five videos per workday.
And I still make videos,
I made one this morning.
I still haven't uploaded yet, it's coming.
It's Simpson's Diversity Index
in biology of how do you quantify
diversity in a population.
Let's see. So Hari asked another question.
"What do you think is the
hardest topic in mathematics?"
You know, what I found is
any topic in mathematics,
it can sometimes seem hard at first,
'cause it's kind of
stretching your thinking,
it's making you visualize
things in a different way,
or it might even be things
that you find trouble visualizing.
Like, I remember the first time,
you know, in linear algebra,
you start generalizing this notion
of two-dimensional, three-dimensional,
and then you go to N-space
that you can have an arbitrary
number of dimensions.
And then you can essentially
do linear algebra
within those arbitrary
number of dimensions.
And mathematically, you can come up
with some really interesting conclusions
about things or insights about things.
And at first, I remember thinking,
how do I think beyond three dimensions?
I mean, maybe we can
think in four dimensions
if you include time, but you know,
the more you get familiar with
it, your brain, it is true,
the human brain cannot really
visualize four dimensions
or definitely not five dimensions,
but you can start to
think about how it works
and actually the math can help
you think about what happens.
What would it be like to experience
if we had four spatial dimensions
or five spatial dimensions
or things like that.
So, you know, I think,
and there's other topics
in mathematics that can be very abstract.
It might seem very esoteric
but what I found is the more,
in any subject, not just math,
that you really apply yourself to it,
you allow your subconscious
to ponder a little bit,
give yourself some time and space,
at some point those
connections are gonna happen.
And I'm actually convinced anything
that is understandable
by any other human being
is actually understandable
just given enough time.
If you go back a thousand years,
things like algebra were considered
like super advanced, like
only the elite of the elite
mathematicians would, you know,
al-Khwarizmi famously is the
one who really invented algebra
and algebra is, you know,
algebra comes from Arabic,
and this was kind of in the golden age
of kind of Islamic mathematics,
I think it coincides with the
famous library in Baghdad.
So back then, for much of the world,
this was like super advanced stuff.
I think this was in the
11th or 12th century,
but you fast forward today,
you start learning algebra in sixth grade,
11 or 12 years old and you
really are supposed to master
algebra or at least the core of it
by the time you're in 9th or 10th grade.
So I think even things like
tensor analysis or typology,
or you know, I could come up
with some of these abstract things.
I think over time, they're gonna
become more and more common
for more and more people to
really understand these things.
So from YouTube, Sudheer Yadav says,
"How could I balance my life
between monthly exams and what
I really wanna do in life?"
Good question.
And I would say the key is balance,
no matter what stage of life you're at,
whether you're a student and
you have to take your exams
and study for them or
whether you're working
and you have some passions
you wanna work on.
I think if you really
determine yourself, you say,
look I am going to set
aside X hours a day.
Maybe it's only an hour a day,
two hours, or maybe it's only three hours
on the weekend to do
this thing I care about.
You should be able to do it.
There's a lot of stuff we do
when we're procrastinating,
not efficient use of time
that when we really think
about it and reflect on it, we're like,
it really doesn't make us feel good.
Let me focus that energy on the stuff
that I really wanna work on.
And, you know I say this 'cause
Khan Academy wouldn't exist.
Y'all heard the story of how it started.
If I said I'm a hedge fund analyst,
that's all I'm gonna do,
my cousin needs help but
I'm gonna ignore her.
Khan Academy exists because I said, look,
this is important to me,
I'm interested in tutoring,
I wanna help my cousin
and I wanna write software,
I wanna help them.
And I'm curious about the
broader problem of education.
Let me carve out some time for this.
And you know, when you do that,
you think it might affect your day job,
but in a lot of ways it doesn't,
and it actually makes you
better at your day job,
because then when you go to your day job,
you're more energized, recharged,
and you're used to thinking
in kind of different ways.
So even now, there's a million
things I wanna get done
with Khan Academy and
when Friday afternoon
or evening comes around and I'm like,
oh, maybe I should just
work through the weekend
and crank that stuff out.
But I remind myself that if I do that,
I'm just going to deplete
myself and actually probably
make me less effective in
my role at Khan Academy.
And that I should invest that time,
be present for my own needs,
for my wife's needs,
for my children's needs.
So that, one, it's for
them, but also for myself.
I think no one on their death bed wishes
that they had worked for
their job a little bit harder.
Everyone on their death bed, I think,
or a lot of folks when on their deathbed,
hopefully a long time from now, they say,
oh, I wish I spent more
time with my family.
I wish I invested more in my passions.
I wish when my kids were young,
I really appreciated them.
I look at videos now of, you know,
my kids are 11, 9 and 6.
And I look at videos from
even four or five years ago
when they were younger and I was like,
man, they were these
little chunky monkeys,
how come I didn't squeeze them all day?
And then I remember how
tiring it was as well,
so I was probably just tired.
But I remind myself that in five years
when I see videos of my own kids today,
I'm gonna be like, oh, look
how cute and adorable they were
and they were so fun and curious.
How come you ignored them
when you were trying to write
that memo to whatever whatever.
And so I just remind myself all the time
it's all about balance
and really prioritizing your
inner self, your family,
and your friendships so
that they don't get lost
and it's not gonna hurt your
other things you have to do
whether it's academics or a job.
So let's see, YouTube,
Susana Garcia Dominguez.
I don't wanna have
favorite question askers,
but Susanna has consistently
ask some very good questions.
So not to make all of y'all feel bad.
I haven't seen the
question she's gonna ask.
She says, "Hello Sal, thank
you for having Homeroom today.
I was wondering about MIT.
Do they have a big endowment?
What scholarships are best to apply for?
What is the best way to fund MIT?"
I'm assuming fund as a
student, if you wanna go.
'Cause MIT is a reasonably
wealthy university.
I don't know what their
endowment is today,
but it's in the billions of dollars.
So, but you know, they do great things.
So if anyone's thinking about funding MIT,
they do some incredible research.
So I'm a big fan.
That's where I went to college.
I'm guessing that's why Susanna
is asking me about that.
But what scholarships are
the best to apply for?
What is the best way to fund?
I'm assuming going to MIT.
So, you know, when I was in high school,
my mom didn't make a lot of money.
I think she was making,
I think $5 an hour,
which even in the 1990s
was not a lot of money,
it was minimum wage.
And my older sister actually
applied to Brown University
which is another very good university,
Ivy League university.
And I remember when she was applying,
I was like, even if you
get in, how are we gonna?
We can't afford going there.
At the time, I think Brown's
tuition was $20,000 a year
which was more than my
mother made in a year.
And then room and board
would have been another $10,000 a year.
So back then it would have
been about $30,000 a year.
Now, these places are
$50,000/$60,000 a year in some cases.
And then my sister told me,
"No, Sal. There's this
thing called financial aid."
And if you get into some
of these universities,
not all universities have them,
but universities like Brown,
universities like MIT that have
reasonable size endowments,
they first of all try to be need-blind
or I think they are need-blind
when they look at an applicant.
So they're not looking at you
whether you're gonna
be able to pay or not.
And then if you get
admitted, they try to make it
so that you can pay.
And actually, and so when I was...
My sister was able to...
She had a good bit of loans,
but then she also had a
lot of grants from school
and then she was able to go.
And so that made me realize,
oh wait maybe I could also think about it,
'cause it was always my dream
when I was young to go to MIT.
A little bit arbitrary,
I remember when I was seven years old,
my uncle who was in his
twenties at the time
at the University of New Orleans,
he was a college student
and he was doing his calculus homework.
And I was like, "What is this?"
He's like, "This is calculus."
I'm like, "What is calculus?"
And he's like, "Well,
it's a little complex."
I was like, "Explain it to
me." And then he explains it.
And I was like, "Why are
you learning calculus?"
He's like, "Well, I
wanna become an engineer.
And then I'll be able to do
X Y, and Z, make things."
And I said, "Then I wanna
become an engineer."
And then he said, "Then
you should go to MIT."
And he doesn't remember saying that
but I remember saying,
"Okay, I will go to MIT."
I didn't know what it stood for,
I didn't know where it was
but something clicked in my
brain at seven years old.
And when I saw that my sister
kind of pioneered that like, oh,
there's this thing called financial aid,
that gave me the confidence to apply.
And even that I realized
at the time was a little delusional.
No one in my high school
had ever gone to MIT
and they only were accepting
at the time five or six people
from the state of Louisiana.
I did not go to one of
those fancy schools,
but somehow I got in.
And they gave me a, I thought,
a very generous financial aid package.
So I did have debt.
I had like $30,000 of
debt when I graduated
but for the most part, all
the contribution came from me
and my work study and my mom
didn't have to contribute much.
And my understanding now
of a lot of these schools,
if your family makes I believe
it's below $75,000 a year,
it's essentially free.
And I think in some cases,
if your family makes below
125,000 or 150,000 a year,
it's still heavily, heavily subsidized.
So any of you all thinking about going,
it's not just MIT or Brown,
there's a lot of
universities, look into it,
that give need-blind admissions
and give very generous financial aid.
So don't let your family's
finances narrow the aperture
of where you might wanna go to college.
Let's see, from Facebook, Maya Campbell,
"If you weren't leading Khan Academy,
what do you think you'd be doing instead?"
So there's a bunch of projects
that I think in the
education space generally
I've always been interested
in the stuff we're doing at Khan Academy.
Some of y'all know I've been working
on this project at schoolhouse.world,
very complimentary to Khan Academy
around peer to peer tutoring.
Although I view that as all part
of the same broader mission,
ways for students to know what they know
so that they can approve it
for things like a college admissions.
Uni of Chicago just announced a couple
of weeks ago that they were gonna
use these schoolhouse.world certifications
for admission cycle this year.
So I think I'd be drawn.
Even when I was working at the hedge fund,
I was saying I'll start a school one day
if I'm able to make enough
money in the hedge fund
'cause I always thought it'd be fun
to be a Dumbledore-type figure.
So I think I would be doing something
in education eventually.
If you're saying if I wasn't
working in education at all,
what would I be doing?
Maybe I would've stayed
in the hedge fund world
to some degree and tried to become...
But even then I would have
viewed that as a means to an end.
And you know, I think my biggest interests
are I mean, my general
interest is in human potential.
And so that's why I'm so
interested in education.
And then a more recent passion
that I've really been developing,
y'all have heard me talk
about it on this live stream
is just kind of going
on an inward journey,
like understanding who we
are as sentient beings.
And so that's why I've
been meditating a lot.
I've been actually investing time
to get to know my friends better.
We meet on Sundays and we have
these, now we do it on Zoom,
where we have these conversations
about what does it mean
to be a good person
and what's perception versus
reality and things like that.
So maybe I would have become some type
of community builder type of
person who knows, who knows.
I also like, on the side
I think I'm always drawn
to kind of real estate.
Maybe I would have been some type
of like home fixer upper.
There's something very
tangible about that.
Like, that's just a random other interest
that I might've had.
A lot of my friends know...
Anyone who I know who
wants to buy a house,
they turn to me right now.
I'm like their shadow real estate broker
'cause it's just kind of a fun thing
that I like to do when I'm
procrastinating. (laughs)
So, Fataha Babur is asking from YouTube,
"How do I learn how to teach?"
Well, the best way to learn
anything is to keep doing it,
getting feedback and really
processing that feedback.
My general, you know, if I were to give...
I haven't thought a lot
about this, but you know,
step one, learn the material
really, really well yourself.
Not only so that it's
really intuitive for you,
but you're excited about it.
'Cause if you don't have excitement
and if it's not intuitive to you,
it's gonna be very hard
to convey the excitement
and the intuition to someone else.
So that's step one.
The second thing is try
to build the empathy
of really putting yourself
in the mind of the person
you're trying to explain to.
Don't try to force the
knowledge into them,
cater to their needs, be
as empathetic as possible,
be as patient as possible,
try to meet them where they
are and just be conversational.
Don't talk down, don't talk above them.
Just say look, we're just two souls
trying to understand this.
I just happen to know it already
and let's see how I can help you.
And I think if you have
that kind of relaxed
but still passionate and very
intuitive angle on something,
people are gonna really
enjoy learning with you
and going on a learning adventure.
That's my gut sense.
Time's going by fast.
Let me do a couple more questions.
"What skill do you think is the
most useful for the future?"
This from Khurram Amir
Mazar from Facebook.
The meta-skill is the
ability to learn things.
The one thing we know
about the next century
is that the rate of change
is only going to accelerate.
There's these famous stats,
I don't know how they come up with it,
that the majority of the jobs
that all of y'all are going to have
10, 20, 30 years from now
don't exist yet today.
So we don't even know what those jobs are.
And so the real skill you need to learn
is how do you pull knowledge.
And the beauty is right now
in the internet through Khan
Academy and other things,
the knowledge is all there.
There's a million ways
to learn the skills.
And so you just have to
get good at doing it.
So when you're on Khan Academy,
yes, you can learn to factor a polynomial
and you can learn about photosynthesis
and you can learn about
the American Revolution
and that's all important content to learn
and skills to learn,
but that meta-skill of
learning at your own time
and space and using tools
at your disposal to do so,
that's really an incredible skill.
And based on the last question,
I think the ability to teach others
is an incredibly valuable skill,
not just for becoming a teacher.
If you think about what a good manager
does in a corporation,
they're good supporters and teachers
and mentors of other people.
You need to communicate when you teach,
you need to empathize when you teach,
you need to inspire when you teach.
And if you think about it,
those three things are
completely synonymous
with leadership or any type
of entrepreneurship as well.
So I would say the ability to teach
and the ability to learn new things.
Let's see, one more question,
or maybe I'll do two
real fast, YouTube, MMBL,
"They say Khan Academy is
a great area for SAT prep.
I really need to raise my
score 200 points or more.
What do you advise me to do?"
You know, if you go on Khan Academy,
use the official SAT
practice which we have
in partnership with the
college board and you put in,
I don't know when you're
planning on taking the SAT,
I'm guessing you might
be a sophomore or junior.
It's a little late now if you're applying
for college right now but
maybe you are, don't stress.
But you know, I would put
in 20/30 minutes a day,
maybe four or five days a week.
And you know, we actually
have done research.
If you follow the recommendations
on the official SAT practice,
the stuff that the software's
saying you need to work on,
you really focus on
leveling up your skills
to kind of higher and higher levels on it.
And every now and then you
take full-length practice tests
in as realistic format as possible,
we see in the data that that's really
gonna drive a lot of growth.
And especially if you have
some time before your SAT
and you just make a habit
20/30 minutes a day,
follow the recommendations,
work on what you need to work on,
take those full-length practice tests.
I think in a few months
you're going to see
pretty noticeable gains.
And if you have even
more than a few months,
I actually feel pretty confident
you'll be able to reach your goals
and maybe it'll happen sooner.
And then, we're all over time.
This one, YouTube, Aten Mera says,
"How do you have so much depth
of knowledge in most domains?
It seems to be quite extraordinary
for a single person to do."
well, I appreciate that
you feel that I have
this depth and, you know, look,
that is one of the things
that why I feel lucky
to have this job that I
get to exercise that depth
in many domains and then
communicate it to other folks.
But I think we're all just curious
beings in this thing we call life,
in this universe that
we're trying to understand.
And almost all knowledge is
just trying to make sense
of who we are and what
the universe is all about.
And what I've found is if
you can draw connections
in one domain, it translates
into other domains
more than you might suspect.
I think in a traditional school system
we silo the subject so
much that you don't realize
that ways of learning and ways
of connection in your brain
are not as siloed as you think.
It's not like your brain
has like a math section
and then separately a physics section
and then separately an art section.
These neurons are all jumbled together.
And so for me, it's very
fun to ponder things,
to learn things, to be
able to communicate things.
And I think if you just have
the mindset for yourself,
like I'm just gonna keep learning,
and I'm just a curious person
and I too wanna learn everything.
I think when you're
sitting in your mid-forties
on a live stream and your
beard is graying a little bit,
people will be sending you
questions like you just sent me.
So thanks everyone for this.
It's always super fun these
these ask me anythings.
A couple of announcements,
tomorrow, October 22nd.
I don't what day is today
is today. Is today the?
The day after tomorrow
we're going to have a motivation webinar
from Kristen DiCerbo, our
chief learning officer.
And I highly recommend this.
Kristen is great.
She is an expert on all things learning
and she is also very engaging herself.
So encourage parents to
check out this webinar
on how to motivate middle
and high school kids
during distance learning.
Also wanna remind folks that tomorrow
we're going to have Pedro Noguera,
the dean of the University
of Southern California's
Rossier School of Education.
And so start thinking of
questions for Dean Noguera.
That's going to be a great conversation.
So, everyone thanks for joining.
These ask me any things are always fun
and I will see you tomorrow.
Onward.